hello welcome back to Mateo from
Australia Today is a fun one today we're
talking about combos so who doesn't like
combos combos is a lot of fun to talk
about and it's also kind of nice to know
like instinctively which combos you
should maybe search for in your own
games so put together 50 combos I think
most of these are really good there are
some here that are a little bit
questionable but I'll get to that once
we get there if you want to see a list
with all the combos I have for you just
go to the end of this video so yeah
let's go so first of all let's get the
city stuff out of the way so we got
standby technology with fastest so this
will allow you to buy the standard
project build a city for 19 Mega credit
instead of 25 and then it'll give you
like two Mega credit production a
placement bonus and a few VP this combo
is fine if you're going for cities it's
nothing amazing but it's okay here's the
more well-known combo immigrant City
Plus thuses and this is for good reason
of course because all of a sudden when
you're building a city you get three
Mega credit production so now if you're
building the standard project it costs
25 then you get three bags so now it
costs 22 and you get like I said 3D grid
collection but with this combo here as
opposed to the first one you don't
really have to go for the standard
Builder city project for 25 you can also
just have silicates in fact City cards
would be much better if you have it so
like immigrant cities thousands and
maybe corporate strongholds or something
that's a really good opening and we are
talking about combos today but I mean
combos could be like a number of
different things as soon as you have
more serious energetic casts like these
stacked together well you can call that
a combo but we already talked about this
a lot in episode three so if you want
more of the city stuff go to episode
three but let's talk some more about
standard technology because this can be
a really strong card and it can combo
with a lot of different things so for
instance we got standard technology Plus
credit card so now you can make the
build a city standard project for 18
Mega credit and it's kind of good like
in the mid to late game when you're like
trying to fill up the map with like
cities and greeneries that can be quite
strong it's basically considering that
with this combo you can also build a
Greenery for 16 Mega credits like in the
late game and especially in the last
generation it's really common that
people actually spend 23 Mega credits
just to get a green return so if you
could do this for 16 it's really good
then we got a fun one standard
technology plus Thor game so now you can
build the standard project power plant
for five Mega credits there's also this
really funny combo that if you also on
top of this have power infrastructure
then all of a sudden you can make one
make a credit production for five Mega
credits I played this like once or twice
and it is so nice that if you just have
mega credits left over in the early game
or if you just have bad cards then you
could just build a bunch of energy and
to turn this energy into gold and it's
it's actually a lot of fun but I
wouldn't say it's complete the game
winning it's just it's fine and also
like we're gonna talk about later in
this video getting three different combo
pieces the odds of getting all three in
a game that's very low then we've got
Advanced LS and flop block so all of a
sudden your titanium is with five Mega
credit per titanium and I mean if you
really go down this road then we could
also consider Mercury and allies and we
can also consider the Audi policy if
you're playing with turmoil so now we
have titanium is worth seven Mega credit
per titanium and then we kind of get to
this point right where well you need
this but then you also need titanium
production and then you also need
something to play a lot of space tags
because otherwise you're just gonna be
stuck with a lot of titanium so it is a
little bit of a stretch to make this
work but that being said it can be
really strong actually having like seal
entertaining that's worth a lot this
could be like a huge boost to the engine
but a combo that's a little more
reliable could be this one iron mining
Industries plus four block and the nice
thing about this one is that the thin
titanium you have to begin with with fat
block all of a sudden you can use this
directly to play Iron mining Industries
because that's 40 right and then just
need one more Mega credit and then you
just paid for this really expensive card
and the other kind of cool thing about
this combo is that it is sort of kind of
10 mega credit production if you can use
the titanium throughout the game those
kind of nice you're really happy if you
see this combo in your opening hand it's
quite good and once again I mean we
could keep going but if you put an
advanced dialers on this it's of course
even better then we've got Arctic algae
with the lakefront resource Corporation
so if you have this then you just need
some more cars and some more stuff that
actually gives you water and then you go
then we've got high tech lab with mass
converter it does require you to get
like another four science tag but let's
say you have this so all of a sudden the
high-tech left that's the last cyan Tech
you actually need to play Mass converter
so if you have these two combined then
you can draw like six cards every
generation and keep one of those and
that's really strong so basically what
I'm saying is high tech labs really good
but it's only good if you have a lot of
energy production like for example Mass
converter never got a lot of stuff with
the Byron cooperation so this
Corporation makes it so you can use
action cards twice in a generation
instead of just once I gotta be honest
in most cases the wiring Corporation is
not that good because you kind of need
one of the good combos to actually make
this cooperation worth it the group is
something like this for example orbital
cleanup of course provided that you have
a lot of science text could also be
margin rails if there are a lot of
cities on the map could also be AI
Central this is like the juicy one this
is maybe one of the best combos you can
have with Byron because just getting
four cards every generation that's
really strong this is actually the combo
I had in real life when I got 280 on on
like 11 Generations or something so what
I had is AI Centric plus viron and then
I also had a bunch of money income so
yeah you know what's coming if you have
a lot of card draw which this is
definitely a lot of capital and if you
couple that with a lot of money income
as well then you are definitely going
god mode so here is also one of the more
well-known combos this is a letter plus
the helium Corporation so let's actually
talk about this a little card for a
second so the card costs three so for 38
you get seven make credit production you
can also use it as heat to get the heat
up so it's a little bit better but let's
say for the sake of argument that it's
seven Mega credit production if that is
the case then you're actually paying 5.4
Mega credit just to get one Mega credit
production so if this is the early game
it's still like okay but if we're
getting to the mid to late game it's not
really that useful to be honest it's
kind of immigration shuttles territory
so it's okay but it's really not that
good but then of course if you pick this
up in the mid to late game likely you
will also have a lot of discount on
Space tags and stuff like this so it
could still be okay so I might be hating
on this a little bit but of course that
being said I'm also slightly happy if I
get this combo to begin with it's it's
okay it's kind of nice other hit combos
could be some of this stuff we talked
about this in previous videos and like
we talked about getting exactly eight
heat production that's kind of worth it
making creative production because it's
the same as one Frontier per generation
so this is kind of good until the
parameter is closed and then it's
useless unless you have like helium or
insulation I can't take a contract now
let's talk about what I think is one of
the absolute best uses for standard
technology in the game and that is
standard Technologies plus Poseidon
because if you watch my previous videos
you'll know that I really enjoy colonies
and I think colonies are very strong so
if you can get just three discount on
all colonies that's just an incentive to
buy all of them and especially if you've
got a presider because then you also get
one Mega credit production every time a
colony is placed so it's even better in
this case just simply having standard
technology with the colonies expansion
that's enough that's like the best use
of standard technology at least in the
early game later on it's really good
with like cities and greeneries but in
the early game honestly this is where
it's this simple it's just standard
technology plus Cardinals it's fine so
here's the combo I showed you in the
first video and this game was just so
easy honestly I had a quality research
plus standard technology plus presiding
Corporation so in my opening hand in the
first few Generations I kept very few
cards I only kept the really good cards
and the reason is this is all I want
this game I just want to build a bunch
of colonies and then when I have all the
available colonies that are just slammed
around the color to research it's very
fun and it's a very effective way to
just Stomp the game to be honest another
Colony combos honestly it could just be
a lot of the stuff you see here I mean
synergies and combos it's very closely
related so it's kind of hard to say when
is it one or the other but here's a
combo I don't think a lot of people are
thinking about because this is really
thinking out of the box on this one so
we got the polyphemus corporation and
this Corporation it to be honest it's
kind of bad it's really a bad
cooperation but it does give you a lot
of stuff to begin with but then the
effect of the corporations is negative
you like you have to pay five Mega
credits every time you buy a car as
opposed to normally you only pay three
and this is including the research phase
this is really terrible so how can you
solve this problem you just play with
colonies honestly especially if Pluto is
available this perfect because Pluto's
draw you a lot of cards and with your
drawing cards for free then obviously
you don't have to pay five to actually
buy a car but there could also just be
some of the other stuff you want do you
want Mega credit production build
Nickelodeon Luna do you want some steel
build a colony in Sarah's do you want to
close the game I don't know really why
you would want that with this
Corporation but it could be the case
then you beat the colonial Iowa and so
on so what I'm trying to say that even
though cars are so expensive with this
coveration colonies just solves a lot of
that you can like get so many different
things with colonies so instead of like
using cards to build your engines you
just build a bunch of colonies then
we've got some of the Green Tech combos
like we also mentioned in previous
episodes so we got ants I've been using
insects the reason these cards are good
is that a microbe and discounts with
half a point so if they can couple this
with like it's a letters or something
it's really good could also be sulfating
bacteria together with insulators this
is like this this combo is actually kind
of fun because it's like your own
personal Luna especially considering
that no one is really going to contest
you they'll only contest you if they
themselves had a good micro card
otherwise you can get into the letters
all to yourself so it really opens up
the door for you to get maybe a double
Colony or maybe even a triple colony in
insulators and that could be really
strong of course imagine if you have a
triple colony in Luna you basically won
the game but now you can do it on
themselatos and maybe people can stop
you but maybe they came so it's just a
fun combo to keep in mind I use this
sometimes and it feels really good but
of course this is only if you play with
the Venus expansion and on top of that
you also need the Venus scale to go to
six so it's not that bad but it can be a
little bit annoying especially
considering that this is more like make
creative production what you're getting
out of this so the fact that the Venus
scale has to be six before I can
actually get this going is a little bit
of line so more realistically especially
in the mid to late game you should
really use insulators together with ants
or venusian insects this is probably a
bit of you then we've got fish plus
large Convoy this is like a classic but
it's a classic for good reason because
all of a sudden large Convoy this card
itself is like worth seven victory
points for you so normally this is a
combo you play in the last generation or
maybe just before the water actually
closes so you can get the last available
TR for the water but it's like when you
think about it in this case last corner
is like equivalent to a Joven amplifier
it's quite expensive but you're getting
a lot of stuff you're getting seven
Victory poems in this case you're also
getting like two cards and then the fish
card itself it also gives you one
Victory point so this combo as a whole
is like eight victory points on top of
whatever fish can get you in future
generations and then we can also throw
Miranda into the mix as well as other
cards or stuff that can just give you
animals so this is why it's really
important to have at least one animal
where the animals are worth one Victory
point of animal and well we added if you
have these combos where you can get a
lot of animals of course if you have
meat Industries this is even better then
we've got extreme cold fungus if you
couple this with regular eaters or dhg
producing bacteria this is like one free
Tiara every generation so that's also
kind of really good so like we talked
about this is also kind of worth like
eight Mega credit production at least
until the parameter closes when the
parameter closes it's really bad again
so regular eaters or THC producing
bacteria I don't think these cards are
very good you really need something like
extreme cold Focus selection and make
these cards worth it I think you could
also use extreme pulled fungus together
with ends of the news in insects to get
at least one Victory Point per
generation and this doesn't stop at any
point this just keeps going until the
game is over it doesn't matter that the
parameter is closed in this case and
instead of extreme cold fungus we could
also put in this card backrobial
research so this is also really nice but
especially ants and venusian insects
because this is a card you want to play
in the last generation extreme cold
funkers together with sulfur eating
bacteria or recycler also very nice of
course then we got this stuff Mars
University plus Olympus conference and
to be honest it's hard to see if this is
just a really good combo or if these two
cards by themselves are just excellent
but nevertheless when I've had these two
cards in my game I've literally never
had a bad game the only way that these
two cards are useless is if you never
draw a science tag after you play these
so it could happen but I mean in most
cases this is just very good the reason
you could call this a combo is that all
of a sudden the bad science tag will now
you just keep it because it's a science
take because iron text does so much for
you right now and like we mentioned in
the previous video These two cards also
get exponentially better if you have
more card draw to go with this so let's
say for example you have Point Luna and
then you have these two cards well now
you are yeah now you're approaching god
mode territory here is a combo that just
got announced like last week or maybe
when when this is out maybe two weeks
ago or something this is triple
Corporation is now common man oh man
this makes me excited so you've got
merger plus double down this means that
you can have three corporations together
in a game you can play with three
corporations at once and that's ah man
it's fun I like this wakanda already had
this but this is only if we played with
user made content but now it's kind of
now you can actually theoretically
happen in the game of terraform Mass
it's very unlikely but it could be a lot
of fun to actually play a game with
three corporations so these combos I
just mentioned these are also combos I'm
using in my theorycraft opening hand
which we talked about in the last video
this is like pure Theory craft but as
you can imagine having all of this stuff
in the same deck is completely insane
and if you couple all of this card Pro
together with Card discount this is also
very strong you could just say a combo
is like Card discount Plus Card Draw and
that's a really good combo as well then
we've got physics complex together with
CEO's favorite project of course also
really good normally you play this combo
in the very last generation of the game
why because first of all you need to
actually have something on physics
complex before I can play this and also
this combo gives you nothing except
Victory point so that's another reason
you want to play this in the very last
generation and finally maybe you pick up
Earth office or something so the CEO's
favorite project can actually like be
better to play in the last generation
maybe you'll regret having played it
earlier so this you just play this in
the last generation that's all three
then we've got physics complex together
with mass converter it's a little bit
the same story like we talked about with
like High Tech Lab plus Mass converter
it's really good if you can get these
together because physics conflict is
another card that requires you to have a
lot of energy production and also
physics conflicts by itself also has a
science tag so this could just be the
last Science Tech you need in order to
play Mass converter then I saw on the
Facebook mask group that someone
mentioned this compost it is this like
the best combo you've ever seen and yeah
it could be if you have literally 12
energy production and then you also need
maybe even more energy production if you
like using energy to trade or something
so this is of course still very good but
it does come with a cost like 12 energy
it's actually a high cost that's all I'm
saying in regards one of the really good
combos robotic Workforce together with
either gyropolis or medical lab this is
magnificent if you're not lucky enough
to get those you can also use this with
strip mine a mohall area and it's
definitely good but it's not maybe as
good as you think because like if we
take strip mine then all of a sudden you
have to spend another two energy
production to actually play this and
worth noting you're not getting the two
oxygen when you're using robotic
Workforce on strip mine because the two
oxygen they are not part of the brown
box if that makes sense and robotic
Workforce only copies the Box itself
Mobile area that's kind of nice of
course getting for heat production for
nine Mega credits that's of course a
really good deal especially if there's a
purpose with the seed so if you're
playing this I'm assuming that you have
a purpose in mind for this year
production then let's look at some
floater combo so we got startopolis plus
Force participation this reminds me a
little bit of the micro combos we saw
earlier like with extreme cold fungus
together with ghd producing bacteria for
example so you're getting one free Tiara
every generation that's kind of good
that's like eight Mega credit production
then you also have two on sotopia self
that's 10. this combo here is a little
bit more expensive because of the two
police but it's definitely worth it
because even if the Venus scale is
closed completely then you can start
pumping floaters on stratopolis itself
because the floaters here are worth one
third of a point then we also got Auto
police plus floating halves this is a
little bit better because the floaters
on floating halves is like worth one
meter point or two floaters instead of
one P3 which it is Unstoppable list so
this combo here is like 1.5 Victory
Point per generation then we've got the
really good late game combo it's
hydrogen to Venus plus floating hams in
the late game this can be like a lot of
points and with noting this is a space
event so probably you have a lot of
discount on the bins or space events or
space tags so this does of course
require you to get some jogians for this
to be good but when you think about it
this is like half of a jovian amplifier
for 11 and then you have a bunch of
discounts so it's kind of good but it is
of course best with floating hands there
are few other cards that can also hold
these Venus floaters Pilots it's not as
good floating apps is definitely the
best card for this you can also use this
like in the mid game and just put it on
something like false participation just
to get one free Venus every generation
also okay and then we got some of the a
little bit less impactful combos I would
say these are still good if you get them
in a game but it's not like broken or
anything so for example we got Florida
technology plus aerial mappers well this
is just like one free card per
generation it's fine it's actually
literally a sub cross measurement if you
think about it could also be floated
Technologies plus Titan shadows in this
case Florida technology is literally a
titanium mine it's kind of funny but I
would argue if a lot of technology is
even better than this because this is
like combo you could be running in the
early game but then later on you can
actually use a lot of Technology
together with another floor card so the
flexibility of Florida technology makes
this a little bit better than the
titanium mine in this case Florida
technology plus local shading I mean in
the early game this is one free Mega
credit production every generation and
these cards are pretty cheap fine and
basically like we talked about you can
look at all of these Florida cards here
a lot of these cards put together are
like combos you know but let's look at
one of the absolute best combos in the
game I'm talking kelp farming plus
ecology expert so yes this does cost you
an entire Prelude and 20 Mega credits
because you actually have to buy the car
and then you have to play kelp farming
but even this man this is completely
worth it because look at what you're
getting you're getting two make a credit
production and four plan production and
then on top of that you get two plans
two plan tags it was definitely worth it
there's literally no case where I would
not keep this in my opening hand if you
see this in my opening hand I keep it no
questions asked and kill farming is the
best one but it could also be like
farming plus ecology experts could also
be trees plus ecology experts could also
be Penguins plus ecology experts
penguish is probably the best animal
card you can have but why do I say
Penguins is better than fish in this
case and the reason is that you really
have to think about when is stuff
actually being played so the way you do
it is first you play all of your
corporations and then you play your
Prelude so when you play this ecology
experts it's very unlikely that anybody
except for yourself actually has a plan
production at this point because the
only way they have plain production is
if they have a cooperation with plan
production equal line or maybe there's
one more I'm not sure if they don't have
the corporation which is unlikely then
they must have it on a pre-load which is
just as unlikely because generally the
preludes with plan production those are
not that strong and also it's only the
people who are actually before you like
if you're a first player you literally
cannot steal plant production from
someone else's preload because you're
gonna play your Prelude before they play
their Prelude so it's very likely you
have to take this plan production from
yourself and that's a little bit awkward
but this combo has been the subject of a
lot of debates so I think it's really
interesting to talk about so for example
if you also have Byron to go with it
then all of a sudden you get two animals
on your card every generation so is this
good so here's a thread a red and Board
Game Geek and it's like an old threaded
from 2019 I'm gonna link it in the
description the basically what happened
is that this is the first video where I
actually wanted to do some research
online because I thought it would be a
shame to actually forgot about a really
funny a really good combo it's a group
of some terrifying mask combo and just
happened upon this random thread on
Board Game Geek this guy's got the he
asked this very interesting question he
said that a player in my latest game was
lucky enough to draw all of the
following during set up fish action lets
you basically add one Victory Point per
turn equality experts Prelude card that
lets you play a card from hand ignoring
fish Global requirement it gives you the
plan production fish needs to reduce
Byron cooperation that lets you repeat a
single action each turn this combo seems
massively overpowered if the game goes
to 10th Generation that combo is worth
20 victory points significantly better
than the three to five victory points
you might otherwise be able to wiggle
out of fish so what is the drawback to
this combo even if you use Baron's
ability on a different card sometimes
you're likely still looking at roughly
15 victory points in a 10 generation
game something like this it just seems
like a huge gain with next to no
downsides at all now I'm not hating on
this guy Scott D I think his question is
very good and it's very nice that he
actually started this entire debate
around it but one of the downsides as I
see it is the value is not really enough
it's like okay but it's not like broken
or anything we'll get back to that in
just a second but the other downside is
that it is of course also very unlikely
to actually draw these three combo
pieces at once but you don't have to
take my word for it instead I refer you
to this nude so this guy Trevor Scott he
actually answered this on the board game
geek thread so he said to put it bluntly
the extreme low probability of drawing
it okay so let's see so I'm assuming
here that you're using all the Venus
next and preloose cards since viron is a
Venus next Corporation and ecology
expert is obviously a preload card so
I'm assuming that you include the
corporation error from the base set if I
love these assumptions are inaccurate
that will obviously change the numbers a
little bit with bass plus colonies
expansions plus Venus next plus Prelude
we are talking about 264 cards 22
corporations and 35 pre-look cards the
chance of throwing fish in the opening
hand is then 10 divided by 264 or 3.79
percent the chance of growing vinyl is
one of the two corporations is two
divided with 22 others nine percent the
chance of growing ecology experts as one
of your four Prelude cards is 4 divided
by 35 so that's 11.43 put all that
together chance of drawing this combo is
80 out of 203 280 or one out of
2541 so that's approximately
0.0394 percent I love this man people
who actually do the math on this as well
oh it's so good so I'm gonna keep going
yes it's actually a straight up
probability like this because there's no
possibility of repeating Cuts feel free
to do the math yourself if you don't
believe me I believe you don't worry
there are some obnoxious powerful combos
in the game no question about it also
recycling plus extreme cool fungus is an
example we actually talked about that
before Omni plus base mirrors plus
equatorial magnetizer is another almost
any cab driven game is going to have
them and there's really nothing you
could do to avoid them except for
further diluting the carpool but that
will add more powerful combinations for
math purposes adding colonies into the
mix will bring the tent this particular
combo or for any combination of one card
one Prelude and one call to 80 out of
332 850 or
0.024 zero percent that makes no sense
there's a zero there but okay about 40
increase so my man Trevor thank you
first of all for actually doing all of
this math if anybody appreciates math
it's me but I just have to make fun of
you a little bit because you just
mentioned that getting three combo
pieces at once is so unlikely and then
immediately you just mentioned that the
only space mirror is equatorial
magnetizer is another good combo and I'm
like well that's just as unlikely isn't
it let's actually talk about the combos
he's talking about here so first of all
extreme cold fungus both recycled I
agree this combo is really good he
mentioned this one then he mentioned
space mirrors plus a controller
magnetizer and I just have to say that
this combo by itself is not actually
that good because what are you really
getting you're getting one Tiara every
generation like we've established that's
like eight Mega credit production which
you're spending seven so if you put some
numbers on it and just assume that you
spend three Mega credits to buy these
two cars all of a sudden you've spent 20
Mega credits just to get one Mega credit
production that's not good the combo
Trevor I have mentioned is that you also
have the Omni Corporation so if you put
all of this together it's it's pretty
nice I wouldn't say this is completely
broken it's just fine to be honest
because once again you are paying 20
Mega credits just to play these two
cards and on top of that with this combo
you're spending 10 mega credits just to
get two TR every generation so that's
good of course but considering you spend
like 20 Mega credits just to get this up
and running it makes me think that it's
okay it's not great it's not bad it's
okay but ladies and gentlemen it doesn't
stop here I'm introducing to you now the
third nerd maybe the biggest nerd of
them all so this is Russ so I'm not
going to read all of this you can pause
the video and read it yourself if you
want but basically first of all he's a
nice guy he said here's my quality of
analysis of the combo sorry for
self-reference oh what a nice guy and
basically after he put this combo
through his math machine then it turned
out to be 59 which is just within the
error bars of 60. basically he's saying
that this is okay he's actually saying
the same as me that this is okay it's
not good it's not bad it's like a pretty
average combo it seems like this guy
Ross knows what he's talking about I
mean if you're throwing this much math
at like a board game geek thread I have
respect for you and I'm humbly bowing
this guy obviously knows what he's
talking about I think that's pretty much
it for this video here's a list of all
the combos we looked at today and I just
wanted to say I made a little bit of fun
of these three guys on the board game
geek thread and they're probably not
watching but if they are I hope you guys
are cool with it and to be perfectly
honest I'm very happy that you're here
I'm really happy that people like you
are starting some good conversations on
Board Game Geek threads and stuff like
this and it's especially that you're
throwing so much math at it I mean
that's that's awesome man I really do
appreciate that but yeah that's pretty
much it thank you so much for watching